hi there reject nation I'm good hey whoa
whoa you hydrate on my time it's awesome
our water it's done water it's not
sponsored we're gonna watch a video
today from mrs. Sally you go check out
her YouTube channel we're gonna watch a
video from what culture one of my
favorite channels of those list videos
ten movies already cancelled in 2019 and
why I say we just hop right into the
Salomon know that we can so close I'm
Andrew yeah go by that okay call me
salamander call me salamander the
greatest fish to ever swim fish don't be
sexist
don't try to make sense stretches out in
front versus metal movies that we have
movies poised to wow us have those
darling films to remind us what feelings
are it's a great time councils it's
bloody February how is this happened
alright starts what I'm here to a sheet
this is what calm and these are 10
movies already cancelled in 2019 years
ago Wow
half bum me out Silver Surfer won't you
believe the strategist of the recently
canceled Fox work going 100 miles per
hour to get the movie off the ground
might have been set for the MCU however
this is maybe jumping the gun because
Fox's projects have slowed down around
the big merger deal with Disney makes s
unfortunately it's being cancelled as
part of Fox and Disney's deal Twitter
source and claimed industry insider
Daniel RPK by Paul Hammond Disney's
presumed reluctance to sanction movies
they might be up for the count as McKay
told MTV who knows maybe in a couple of
months it could pop up I really am
excited about that idea number 9
canceled this was technically canceled
back in 2017
however in 2018 there was renewed talk
of the project which apparently was
going to be titled awakening according
to birth movies death bump was the 40th
anniversary of the first alien in 2019
with me we'd see concrete confirmation
of the film especially when social media
accounts linked to the franchise teach
that the universe would be expanding
this year how could that not be the
perfect opportunity to unveil a new
movie and he's more of awakening however
that was Walt ruined when fox clarify to
Variety that there is no new alien movie
being worked on run for release sky
there is no reason that a Disney
wouldn't look to make a new one seeing
as it would be a
purchase a box in the first place
expecting it soon won't be asking too
much though so it seems unlikely we'll
see we'll hear any screams in space
anytime soon
no thanks gambit ah will they won't they
story was originally planned to appear
after x-men origins Wolverine first
dropped yes that's not dampened channing
tatum's desire to become the
smooth-talking card shark
he's been attached to the project
through three different directors with
the white doug liman and gore verbinski
at each and every time it looked like it
was finally about to happen yes and I
hate to sound like a broken record
gambit was another of the Fox Marvel
movies that is now just being cancelled
by see here I wanted it was always the
metal Harris at those movies even
without a murder to be honest but now is
done in the future you'd have to suspect
that Disney would seek to put gambit
back in the main x-men movies at least
didn't plan to set them apart from the
ones that came before number 7 World War
Z tomorrow as a busser all getting
excited about the quite strange news
that none other than David Fincher was
making the long-awaited World War Z
sequel the original had been one of Brad
Pitt's highest-grossing movies of all
time and paramount seemed to believe
that there was sadly this film was
labored in developmental howl since 2013
eventually the boom did enter the
pre-production quite recently giving us
all hope that it was actually happening
but then much like the mood at the orgy
when your mother drops her wrote to
reveal a body mesh stocking that makes
her look like a piece of ham tied in
strain it was killed in it and so
exactly was talking about
[Music]
over budget and required extensive
reshoots that it was canceled because of
budgetary issues which guaranteed a
profit then of course serious budgeting
and you'd have to think the future
wouldn't be involved by there I mean
he's not the type of person yet leaving
alert for too long
number six the Joker's solo movie and
Holly and the Joker
oh is that officially canceled this both
once contained thankfully they don't
anymore it kind of makes sense to
consolidate the field a bit now seeing
as the Joker film starring Joaquin
Phoenix is set to drop soon and have two
jokers one of them confuses the image
somewhat you might still pop up as the
Joker in the upcoming TV show that
Warner Brothers are teasing and making
but once again that's not really yeah
even worse is when you realize that the
Harley and Joker movie was literally
only going to be made because Warner
Brothers felt that Suicide Squad had
completely messed up the matter of his
relationship so wanted a do-over but it
next sets to cancel Harley's film
because she is also getting a solo
Alti in birds of prey which will be
coming out in the near future and again
too many versions don't spoil the
greasepaint
x-force back into right to rat rod
Reynolds would be back as well and so
super Josh Brolin as well as some of the
other supporting cast members rumor also
has it that Olivia Munn psylocke might
return and that Logan's x-23 would also
what project might as well be labeled as
canceled has been no official line that
is out the door but according to
two months from now with so many other
cameos attached this is an x-men offer
least in the Disney is unlikely that it
will make the cut after the merger I
hate to say it but multiple isn't much
of a draw how great his solo stuff could
be it's unlikely to get before this all
these extra movies moment and it's here
that we can wheel out the old dead
because of the deal line again because
it's just being canceled as part of the
merge of Jesus we should just call this
list ten films made by Fox do not cancel
by this right anyway will we see this
film picked up by Disney well there is a
stronger chance but
one than most others solely because the
mfcq has reportedly been making a
beeline for female lead franchises and
having one of the key members of the
x-men who might be able to avoid
returning as Captain Kirk's father would
have seen even was unfortunately in an
effort to negotiate the Fantastic Four
as much it was just to pay homage to one
of the best going as no really no idea
well we asked a question is a hero
is he a villain what does he really want
and that it was going to be a film but
all these questions in a series
speak to you soon I like how this list
started off with two Fantastic Four
spin-off characters here number 10 being
Silver Surfer Adam McKay I had no idea
was attached to make that movie it's
kind of crazy to see how Fox wanted to
basically do all these like movies
within their two universes they had of
x-men and Fantastic Four all of them
have been scrapped since the Disney Foxx
merger and the Silver Surfer movie would
have been cool that McKay behind it that
would have been like a lot of different
energy it would have been very political
- yeah they should add a penis of the
Silver Surfer though distracting or I
would have been really funny and I feel
like what they need is something funny
that's why we can't do it because of
freaking Disney the alien sequels I am
so glad this is getting cancelled I saw
the last sailing movie that was fine
actually I wasn't on the hate train for
it it did seem like Ridley Scott who
created the first alien movie and then
came back many years later to do this it
seems like he just really wanted to
explore this but had really nothing new
to really offer to the table for it I
was excited about the alien Neill
Blomkamp movie where they were gonna
pick up exactly after alien to aliens
forget about that you didn't know about
that
they were gonna forget about all the
other sequels and just pick up and do
its own part 3 I was excited about that
but Ridley Scott's like no my franchise
I started this
I want to keep it going they might as
well be actually not a bad idea to start
is to start fresh but they're not going
to those movies are making billions of
dollar salary that's what they thought
would happen with a lien and gambits
this movie was supposed to start I knew
the guy who was doing the makeup for it
and he was gearing up like yeah we're
gonna go into production in a month I
remember him telling me that and poor
Channing Tatum who's been practicing
cajun cake Asian Cajun Cajun what are
you doing I'm trying to say the place
where gambit is from
Cajun accent Cajun I'm supposed to be
the one who's dumb and you're supposed
to be the one who's smart you're not
John yeah you have enough features the
long hair the pale skin the ass or maybe
John has a great ass
or maybe I shouldn't be saying any of
these words and I'm gonna get in trouble
with everyone I know we're moving on
jokes people John has wonderful breasts
just like salary so this little bit is
am i insulting John her complimenting
job or vice versa I live with the guy it
happens but I do think gambit going into
the MCU would probably be the best way
to do it because x-men already has all
these confusing timelines and gambit was
an x-men origins Wolverine I know they
successfully did it with Deadpool but
they at least took Ryan Reynolds out of
that they were gonna get a whole new
actor to play gambit chanting - and I
was excited for that I feel like Chinese
team could do the role so hold still see
him told him MCU University we had the
gambit property we'll go over to the MCU
territory
I so would love it if they kept Channing
Tatum attached to do it hopefully Kim
fight he doesn't get all Kevin Feige
about it it was World War Z getting
cancelled World War Z one one way over
budget I don't believe that I don't
believe it that's the only reason what
do you think it is Brad Pitt he's hard
to work with them like I know that he's
like really going through going through
a hard time but he is in the new
Tarantino movie that's turned you know
like anyway the first World War Z movie
went way over budget
like way back they might have just
broken even because they had to pretty
much double it after shooting it for so
many months I don't think it profit
to the point where they're like oh yeah
well well add double the budget for the
next movie cuz I was excited for this
David Fincher and Brad Pitt have done
several movies together Fight Club
Curious Case of Benjamin Button 7 so the
idea of them like doing another movie
together for it to be the follow-up and
for David Fincher to be doing it zombie
movie son it's super cool to me to Co
make a comparison of them doing Mission
Impossible seven and eight back-to-back
is different because those movies have
proven to be wonderful profit-making
machines for Paramount Pictures world's
World War Z would be a much bigger risk
I think yeah the risk factor is more so
than the budget they just didn't want to
take the risk because doing any sequel
to anything that big is just it's a lot
also the time that's gone by a long time
yeah I feel like if they were on this
like a year after like yeah I could see
them because there's still be hype for
it as opposed to now we were like oh
yeah World War Z that movie The Joker's
solo movie and the Harley and the Joker
were they talking about Margot Robbie's
movie as well because she was just gonna
have a Harlequin movie they were gonna
have a Harley Quinn movie but now she's
the lead of the birds of prey movie
walking Phoenix does have his Joker
movie coming out but the way when DC
reports their news a lot of the time is
the first off they announced like 45
movies at once you never know which ones
really going through development until
you see a trailer for it even then it
can still be a little suspicious even
when the joaquin phoenix one was
announced they're like no that's a
totally separate thing what your letters
are still around
I think they've completely scribed here
like the response that they've had to
Jared Leto wasn't great he's already
doing the Morbius film for Sony they're
slowly let people kind of forget about
it or not even a squawking joker comes
out
ain't no again remember you see the test
photos for that well yeah we'll see
we'll see we'll see I'm gonna be the
first one to come out and say it just to
justice cause it's winter storm we're
gonna say Joaquin Phoenix the first five
minutes of it already better just to
piss off of people on the Internet
my brain did you see Deadpool - absolute
kana diamond because of what happened on
set I know this a group that was there
for the accident that killed on that fat
boy I kill him with that pool - sorry I
didn't see it it was a really massive
situation sorry I still would have
wanted the x-force movie Drew Goddard
man bad times the Elroy was great I love
when he works with in Samba Liz it's
really crazy to see like most of the
movies on here are films that are
canceled was the Disney Foxx merger my
problem I love Disney do you remember
when they were gonna do their first
horror film the Haunted Mansion with
Ryan Gosling Guillermo del Toro's that
Riggin that was them so my thing was
like I know Disney has been open to
getting a little more darker but my
issue is that it's still Disney so I
feel like a lot of what we were
expecting from Fox just if Disney takes
it on it's just not it's not gonna be
what we're expecting I heard something
that they're planning on doing a
different type of Marvel banner to do
r-rated material okay I don't know if
that's confirmed or if that's just
something I think I heard for sure right
about that but I don't know if it's a
confirmed thing from like Kevin Feige
over at Marvel or something like that
but they do want to do something like
that
kind of like Disney owns ABC but they
can solve adult content on ABC yeah it's
just to make to make a distinction for
their like MCU timeline and to have like
a different thing going it gets kind of
confusing because they were like Black
Widow is part of the MCU but they want
to do an r-rated Black Widow movie so
then that's like wait a minute though so
if they continue Deadpool and that's
r-rated now it gets kind of confusing
because are they trying to say Deadpool
is not part of the MCU official timeline
that's where they're putting in this
r-rated banner but if you're putting
Black Widow over there are will usually
figures it out they're pretty good at
they had like movies in store like foxes
I had no idea about
I didn't heard about the multiple Man
one I don't think people would have
cared about that and I heard about the
I'm sure there are fans out there for
the multiple Man comics but you know
like the Kitty Pryde character - I feel
sorry for Ellen Page
because the two x-men films she was
involved in were under the helms of some
terrible directors and Brett Ratner and
Brian singer poor poor poor Ellen Page
however but she was exception and can't
really beat that yeah and the Doctor
Doom III you know why this is number one
that would have been the coolest it
would have been the freakin coolest they
tried the fantastic four movies twice
and Doctor Doom they've they've
obliterated him so much and I feel like
getting a dr. doom movie would be cool
but to see him in the MCU oh I am out of
all these characters listed here more
than like Deadpool or a gambit or
whatever Doctor Doom in the MCU is
something that really genuinely excites
me yeah I've ridden the dr. doom ride
Universal no it's so creepy and I'm like
why doesn't he come across this theme
park ride is like creepy even like maybe
that's a good point I just think he
deserves a big movie a second third
cancer for a second I thought he said I
wrote Doctor Doom I did I wrote a guy
named doctor I'm like wow
earth-shattering jokes today guys before
we wrap this video up I would like to
give a page from the day shot to a man
named TJ totally jumbled totally jumbo
totally jumbled does like Sally Lomonaco
very much so I know I it's always a
conscious I was really bad but TJ is
actually his wife is taking a trip to I
think Reno and he was saying that while
she's gone he wanted to take a trip to
LA and watch Avengers end game with us
really I said no you leave me alone
freak stay puts the patreon page but
stay out of my real personal life is off
camera I'm very condescending
I'm very snobbish
and I don't like the people who support
us that's why we're friends they don't
support him
we don't camera people know that sure
come watch avengers endgame with us now
if anyone else wants to come watch
Avengers endgame oh man look what you
started TJ look what you started
he won he won yeah you guys can go watch
Wonder Park with me it's really the real
rejects click that notification bell
follow Sally on the youtubes catch you
guys soon